yeah two seven hello Ray here uh HIPAA
Berry from Entertainment Tonight
congratulations
Namaste uh what does this feel like
taking it back to India the motherland
yeah it feels like uh like a just a sang
my most favorite song just a while back
it feels like top of the world standing
on the top of the world and I'm very
feeling very proud for my country and my
the whole team who just dedicated their
energy and time for this song including
Mr Chandra Bose thank you yeah
all right two seven seven and then three
yeah
that's right that's right
thank you that has
56 letters
so Telugu has 56 letters we have lot of
words lot of Expressions a lot of
feelings in our language very great
language and very literary language very
musical language telugues if we write an
ordinary word it will sounds like a
music
so the in this song in RR Telugu lovers
will love the meaning but non-telugu
people like you people are loving the
song means this kind of sounding the
kind of music inside the song that make
this possible
all right we'll move on to three three
eight and then two eight four three
three eight yeah
yes yes please
yeah yeah hi
excuse me
thank you hi Nicolette Morales with
country Focus Magazine congratulations
on your Oscar thank you very much that's
you made history tonight so I just want
to know how does it feel and what does
it mean to you personally to represent
your culture and and to make such a big
win with that amazing song what's going
through your mind I mean how does it
feel yeah right now I'm in Cloud Nine
and uh I feel very blessed to back this
kind of greatest recognition of the
world for my country for my culture for
my motherland and my for my movie
industry from Telugu language it feels
so great
the only thing running in my mind now
present is I have to go to India I have
to I want to show this hour to my wife
and my children
thank you
eight followed by three one
yeah low right here uh
that was right down the middle uh
Jonathan Landrum Associated Press right
yeah right here
um I spoke to the both of you um you
know after you receive your nominations
um and I remember you spoke about
um you know bringing more recognition to
um other artists in India
um can you talk a little bit more about
that and how you just kind of Paving
away
um you know for others you know like
yourself yeah it's I feel this is all
about it's just the beginning of
everything so so that the world
particularly the Western World focuses
more on Indian music and Asian music
which is long due and I I feel uh very
happy but it is like opening doors for
the um
the world to embrace our culture and
music hereafter
three one four and three one four last
question
hello kirwani sir and John debriser
congratulations thank you very much
Sunil from American Kahani we spoke
before yeah
um what was the inspiration behind not
to Nato
yeah NATO NATO is the uh the pure
original uh cultural
genre of Indian music particularly South
Indian music which has lots of
percussions and The Rustic
texture of the music and to bring it out
with the beautiful words written by
Chandra Bose and beautiful steps
composed by our choreographer Prem rat
so it's a great deal of teamwork which
brought us this far and to back this
greatest award
and the lines I wrote in the song all
are my experience in my Village
foreign